ma chambre tu les aimes ou tu la quittes
et les choses ont pas mal changé des
pipes
[Musique]
du coup ils ont tous débarqué chez moi
dans ma cité [ __ ]
tu es
comment je fais pour faire plus local et
qui dit mode chillou mashaal machin au
noir ou ya c'est la route à la metula
bas
ça c'est moi sami benboudaoud ya dix ans
j'ai rencontré pour la première forme ou
charmant cousin charles des chazelles ma
chambre tu les aimes ou tu la quittes à
neuilly sous sarko qui navigue plutôt
douce
mais les choses ont pas mal changé
depuis ma famille n'a pas du tout digéré
la défaite de sarkozy
enfin surtout charles d'un cancer du
cerveau
non c'est une sarkozyte aiguë mon oncle
et son ex-femme s'entendent toujours
aussi bien qu revue admet un but peut
dire que mon oncle a eu quelques petits
soucis avec la justice avait vous
incombe pas d'amis du coup ils ont tous
débarqué chez moi dans ma cité à
nanterre voilà voilà
bienvenue c'est pas choisi le statu quo
et ils ont eu comme un petit choc
ta famille ici gucci chapa mais c'est
bon pour ce que ta [ __ ] surtout
charles a été créée en mai cris quoi
allez-vous sa main a touché mon amour à
limoux avec des gains pour sa mère non
mais on est où là c'est quoi ça écoute
moi bien panoramix les thermos cousin
c'est pas un looser il a repris sa vie
en main
ben voilà c'est fini la guerre du feu
pour moi la bonne nouvelle c'est que tu
va mieux je me présente à la mairie de
nanterre la mauvaise c'est que t'as pas
changé comment je fais pour faire plus
local et qui déboule chez nous comme
sarthe la famille d'un vilain jamais de
chez l'homme mashal a chassé la route à
la metula pas
mental quand on a touché le fond et
quant au coeur montée
j'ai longtemps pour gagner cousin allez
moi je veux tu perdes comme une grosse
merde quoi je serai en quelque sorte un
peu votre mac rond mais de gauche
[Musique]